[Music]
ever since I was a kid my hair was
everything I had to be fixed only then
was I perfect perfect you might go to
girl good job tonight is gonna be the
happiest moment of my life what do you
get the perfect woman
Miep Lola
I was expecting a ring you said I'm
perfect 24/7 perfection you never let
your hair down you don't want you on the
account you can sponsor like six kids
with them when you spend it for your
hair excuse me I apologize to my
daughter she knows better Wow
just be yourself who would that be anal
compulsive miss perfect cut or the not
fun never spontaneous weave well
personally I really like believe that
worked so hard to be perfect and it
still wasn't enough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you think this is just something you did
okay I think you've been building up to
you gotta own it girl yes where are you
going to do
but brother is born as a woman who's
real my dad won't let me perm my hair
you don't need to do that this craziness
has got to stop
that's right that's right
my hair was like a second job now I'm
forced to focus on myself
I wonder who I'll be
you